Isabel II tuvo el reinado más largo de la
historia británica.
Tras su pérdida, Carlos III se ha convertido
en el monarca, en el Jefe de Estado del Reino
Unido.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, esta sucesión
es un asunto que va mucho más allá de las
islas británicas.
Porque Carlos III también es el nuevo rey
de otros 14 países repartidos por América
y Oceanía, algunos tan importantes como Canadá
y Australia.
¡Pero esperad que hay más!
Carlos III también es el nuevo jefe de la
Commonwealth, una organización que agrupa
a 56 naciones soberanas entre las que se incluyen
países como India, Pakistán, Malasia, Nigeria
y Sudáfrica.
Por eso el 9 de septiembre todo el planeta
estaba pendiente del Palacio de Buckingham.
La expectación entorno al discurso del Rey
fue enorme:
En su discurso, Carlos III puso mucho empeño
en subrayar que nada va a cambiar respecto
a su madre.
Sin embargo, en la era de las redes sociales,
su principal problema es que no es su madre.
Isabel II era una figura muy querida y ampliamente
aceptada.
Y el nuevo rey, que queréis que os diga,
no parte con esa mochila.
Por eso, la pregunta es: ¿Qué podemos esperar
de Carlos III del Reino Unido?
¿Cómo puede afectar a la Commonwealth y,
por tanto, a la influencia británica este
cambio en su liderazgo?
¿Puede acelerar la conversión a repúblicas
de algunos de los 14 países más allá del
Reino Unido sobre los que reina la corona
británica?
Pues bien, hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder
a estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
T1(LA ARAÑA NEGRA)
1917.
Nos encontramos en plena Primera Guerra Mundial.
Los Gotha bombardean Londres.
Y no, no se nos ha colado ningún guión de
Megaprojekts sobre estos bombarderos pesados
de la aviación alemana.
Los Gotha son importantes porque por aquel
entonces el imperio británico estaba regido
por la Casa de Sajonia-Coburgo y Gotha.
Vamos, una dinastía más alemana que las
salchichas de Frankfurt.
Como os podéis imaginar, en plena guerra
con Alemania, esto no les hacía ni pizca
de gracia a los ingleses.
De tal forma que el rey Jorge V, el bisabuelo
de Carlos III, se dio cuenta de que su propia
supervivencia y el futuro ede su familia como
soberanos británicos pasaban por renunciar
sí o sí a todos sus títulos alemanes.
Y como decimos por aquí en VisualPolitik,
dicho y hecho.
Así de bien lo reflejó Leonard Raven-Hill,
un caricaturista de la revista Punch.
(IMAGEN JORGE V BARRIEND)
De esta forma nació una nueva dinastía:
los Windsor.
Renunciando a lo ✓que eran y adaptándose
a lo que se esperaba de ellos como monarcas
del Imperio.
Posiblemente ésta sea la mejor enseñanza
que Carlos III ha podido sacar de la historia
de su familia.
Una lección sencilla pero complicada de llevar
a la práctica tal y como demostró el tío
abuelo de Carlos.
Eduardo VIII, que renunció al trono para
casarse con Wallis Simpson, por aquel entonces
un amor imposible al ser esta una mujer divorciada.
Ahora bien, Carlos III tuvo en casa a una
gran maestra en el oficio de la realeza.
(Isabel II cumplió a la perfección durante
7 décadas con el papel de reina.
Experta en el arte de hablar mucho y nunca
decir nada, absolutamente nadie en estos 70
años pudo reprocharle haber roto con su deber
de permanecer neutral en el debate público.
Ni siquiera lo hicieron los nacionalistas
escoceses, cuando ante el referéndum por
la independencia celebrado en 2014 la reina
Isabel recomendó a la gente pensar mucho
sobre su voto.)
Carlos ha sido el Príncipe de Gales durante
64 años.
Ser el eterno heredero ha hecho que esté
siempre bajo los focos.
Lo sabemos prácticamente todo de él.
Quizás demasiado.
Por eso no vamos a volver a contaros la telenovela
que llevamos 30 años viendo repetida una
y otra vez.
Evidentemente, hablamos de un historial que
ha perjudicado su imagen pública.
Pero lo verdaderamente llamativo de Carlos
es su tendencia a expresar sus opiniones sobre
asuntos de lo más diverso.
Una tendencia que ha llegado, incluso, a provocar
algún que otro incidente diplomático.
¿Queréis algún ejemplo?
Pues…
Fijaos.
('Un desaire deliberado': el príncipe Carlos
se saltará el banquete con el presidente
Xi Jinping
Carlos es partidario del Dalai Lama, el líder
espiritual tibetano exiliado a quien China
considera un separatista peligroso.)
China nunca ha sido vista con buenos ojos
por Carlos III.
Sin ir más lejos, el pasado mes de agosto
de este 2022 señaló que Beijing debe contaminar
menos para que la lucha contra el cambio climático
pueda tener éxito.
Y es que hablamos de un soberano que como
príncipe ha tenido siempre opiniones muy
claras.
Por ejemplo, el calentamiento global siempre
fue una de las grandes preocupaciones de este
príncipe de Gales, pero no la única.
También ha sido un gran defensor del reciclaje
y desde hace décadas tiene su propia marca
de alimentos orgánicos.
[Sí, la preservación del ecosistema es toda
una prioridad para este monarca.
Y cuándo hablamos de ecosistema nos referimos
tanto al medio ambiente como a las propias
tradiciones y la cultura local.
Porque Carlos III se atreve con todo.
Arremetió incluso con un proyecto para ampliar
la National Gallery porque el edificio propuesto
era demasiado moderno.
Mirad.
Al final este proyecto no salió adelante.
Pero en lo que respecta a Carlos III está
claro que el papel de príncipe no es exactamente
el mismo que el de rey.
Pensadlo bien, decir que hay algo que no te
gusta, te coloca directamente enfrente de
los que no opinan igual.
Y a los Windsor, lógicamente, les conviene
que todos los británicos les identifiquen
como sus reyes, como un símbolo del estado
equiparable a la bandera y al himno.
Y por eso podría ser un problema si llegado
el caso a este monarca le da por el activismo.
Ya lo fue cuándo el príncipe Carlos se transformaba
en Black Spider, la Araña negra.
(Los memorandos Black Spider son una serie
de cartas escritas por el príncipe Carlos
de forma anónima para enviárselas a primeros
ministros y miembros del gabinete.
Se llaman así por los garabatos con los que
Carlos de Inglaterra trataba de enfatizar
las principales cuestiones que le preocupaban.
Por ejemplo, presionó a Tony Blair para que
no prohibiera la caza del zorro y recomendó
dar carta blanca al sacrificio de los tejones
para combatir la tuberculosis del ganado.
Se atrevió incluso a inmiscuirse en la guerra
de Irak y criticar lo que consideró "deficiencias”
de los helicópteros Lynx.)
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que no parece que
vaya a ocurrir.
A medida que la reina Isabel envejecía, y
consciente de que su llegada al trono era
cuestión de tiempo,el eterno heredero se
ha esforzado por tranquilizar a los británicos.
El mismo lo dijo cuando aún era el heredero:
Black Spider pertenece al pasado.
Cuestión de incentivos supongo.
El caso es que a Carlos III le ha llegado
el momento de ser rey a una edad en la que
lo habitual para los británicos es estar
bailando pajaritos en Benidorm o en cualquier
otro rincón del mediterraneo que les brinde
mucho sol y mucha playa.
Que un heredero genere dudas es habitual,
incluso cuándo su papel es en la práctica
tan limitado.
Claro que en este caso juega a su favor haber
tenido tanto tiempo para prepararse.
Ahora le toca gestionar la herencia de su
madre.
Y cuando decimos herencia, hablamos de una
herencia con mayúscula.
Atentos.
T2 (ELEGIDO POR UN DÍA)
Además de la Corona, la herencia de Isabel
II deja para Carlos III un jugoso legado:
el Ducado de Lancaster.
Hablamos de una cartera de activos, negocios,
terrenos y propiedades por valor de unos 750
millones de euros.
Eso sí, al convertirse en monarca, Carlos
ha pasado el ducado de Cornualles, valorado
en más de 1.000 millones de euros, a su hijo
William, el nuevo heredero.
Y es que la familia real británica no anda
precisamente corta de recursos.
Y de hecho, lo más curioso es quizás el
perfil empresarial que tiene su financiación.
Por ejemplo, los beneficios que genera la
gestión de estos ducados se destinan a sufragar
los gastos privados de los miembros de la
familia real.
De hecho es básicamente de este pastizal
de dónde ha sacado Carlos el dinero con el
que ha financiado todas sus obras benéficas.
[Oye, no está nada mal]
Claro que luego está la auténtica joya de
la Corona, el llamado Crown Estate, valorado
en unos 20.000 millones de dólares.
(El Crown Estate es el patrimonio público
del soberano.
Una colección de tierras y propiedades que
incluye el hipódromo de Ascot, una gran parte
del centro de Londres así como del lecho
marino de Gran Bretaña.
Teóricamente pertenece a la Corona pero realmente
se administra de forma independiente por una
corporación gestionada por el Gobierno.
El año pasado sus beneficios fueron de unos
350 millones de euros.
Pues bien, en función de estos beneficios,
se calcula la subvención soberana, esto es,
el dinero que el país da a los Windsor para
cubrir sus gastos de personal, sus viajes
y el mantenimiento de los palacios.)
Para que os hagáis una idea, normalmente
el monarca recibe el 15% de las ganancias
de Crown Estate de los dos años anteriores
y el gobierno británico se queda con el resto.
Sin embargo, se acordó que entre 2017 y 2027
la Casa Real recibiría el 25% para remodelar
el Palacio de Buckingham.
Esto supone que durante el bienio 2021-2022
están recibiendo unos 100 millones de euros.
Unas cantidades que posiblemente se incrementarán
en los próximos años porque el Crown Estate
es una auténtica máquina de hacer dinero.
[De verdad, no os podéis hacer una idea de
qué manera el viento sopla a favor de los
Windsor.]
(La reina Isabel gana una millonada con los
parques eólicos marinos del Reino Unido)
Así que aunque la subvención soberana se
vuelva a limitar al 15%, los arrendamientos
marinos para levantar parques eólicos está
llenando a toda velocidad el tesoro real.
Y luego, al margen de todas estas cantidades
están los gastos de seguridad de la Casa
Real.
Se estiman en otros 100 millones de euros
y son sufragados por la Policía Metropolitana.
No obstante, parece que ahora Carlos III va
a reducir el número de miembros de la familia
que participan en actos oficiales para así
aligerar esta factura.
Sea como sea, lo que es seguro es que ésta
no es la mayor de sus preocupaciones; porque
la cuestión es que la herencia de su madre
también tiene un gran inconveniente: ser
comparado constantemente con Isabel II.
Y eso no promete ser nada fácil.
(Que Carlos no despierta las mismas simpatías
que Isabel es algo que la propia reina conocía
perfectamente.
Y por eso, consciente de ello, Isabel II se
esforzó mucho en conseguir que su hijo recibiera
el mayor honor que aún mantiene a nivel internacional:
ser el jefe de la Commonwealth.
Y es que en contra de lo que mucha gente piensa,
este cargo no pertenece a la Corona del Reino
Unido sino que es designado por los líderes
de todos los países integrantes de este particular
club.)
De hecho, la reina no quiso que esta cuestión
quedará en el aíre tras su fallecimiento,
así que ya en el año 2018 se encargó de
dejarlo todo atado y bien atado.
(El príncipe Carlos será el próximo jefe
de la Commonwealth
Los líderes estatales cumplen los deseos
de la Reina y acuerdan que el Príncipe de
Gales debería suceder al monarca.)
Y ahora sé lo que muchos estáis pensando.
Pero a ver, esto de la Commonwealth…
¿no es algo así como la sombra del imperio?
¿Algo que se inventaron los British para
mantener la tutela sobre sus antiguas colonias?
Pues bueno, quizás es lo que intentan transmitir
desde Londres, pero en realidad se trata de
una organización internacional como cualquier
otra.
De hecho actualmente forman parte de la Commonwealth
países que no tienen ningún vínculo histórico
con Reino Unido como Gabón, Mozambique, Ruanda
y Togo.
Oficialmente esta organización persigue dos
objetivos: fortalecer la democracia entre
sus miembros y fomentar el desarrollo económico.
El problema es que no tiene la influencia
para conseguir lo primero ni tampoco el dinero
para alcanzar lo segundo.
Algunos defensores del Brexit intentan presentar
de alguna forma, la Commonwealth como una
alternativa a la Unión Europea.
Pero está claro que hablamos de cosas muy
diferentes.
De hecho hay quien incluso duda del futuro
de esta organización una vez que ha desaparecido
la reina y que el Reino Unido no parece atravesar
sus mejores momentos.
Evitar este escenario y reforzar esta organización
será el primer reto que tendrá el nuevo
rey.
En juego está, ni más ni menos, que el papel
internacional de los Windsor y sobre todo
buena parte de la influencia británica.
Pero este no es el único reto que tiene por
delante.
Una crisis más probable es que alguno de
los 15 países donde los Windsor continúan
ostentando la jefatura del Estado traten de
convertirse en una república.
¿De qué países hablamos?
Pues, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3 (¿ERA DE REPÚBLICAS?)
Desde luego, si algunos de los llamados Reinos
de la Commonwealth se convirtiera en repúblicas
no se podría culpar a Carlos III.
La propia Isabel II vio cómo 15 países decidieron
dar este paso durante su reinado.
Hablamos de países como Pakistán, Sudáfrica,
Nigeria, Malta, Fiyi, Mauricio y Barbados.
De hecho, este último, la patria de Rihanna,
se convirtió en república el pasado noviembre.
Y oye, por eso de favorecer la normalidad
en el proceso, al acto asistió el entonces
príncipe Carlos.
Pues bien, el caso es que de los actuales
15 Reinos de la Commonwealth, hay uno que
tiene especial aversión hacia su nuevo rey.
¿Alguna idea?
Pues…
Fijaos.
(El príncipe Carlos respaldó el polémico
despido del primer ministro australiano, revela
una carta)
Esta carta salió a la luz en el 2020 y hace
referencia a uno de los episodios más oscuros
de la historia aussie: la crisis constitucional
de 1975.
Resulta que el gobernador general de Australia,
el representante de la monarquía británica
para ejercer las funciones del jefe de Estado,
destituyó al primer ministro laborista.
El Gobierno atravesaba por aquel entonces
un momento de profunda debilidad y el gobernador
acabó con él de un plumazo.
Nombró primer ministro al líder de la oposición
y dio inicio a 8 años de gobierno de la coalición
entre liberales y conservadores.
Muchos consideraron que el gobernador se había
sobrepasado completamente en sus funciones
y eso despertó un fuerte sentimiento republicano.
Eso sí, en 1999 tuvieron su oportunidad.
El gigante de Oceanía celebró un referéndum
para convertirse en república pero el intento
fracasó por 10 puntos.
Sin embargo, 2 décadas después, la publicación
de esta correspondencia privada que sugiere
que la monarquía británica ejercía una
influencia considerable en la política australiana,
ha dado argumentos renovados a un bloque republicano
que lleva liderando las encuestas bastantes
años.
De hecho, para 2021 los partidarios del sistema
monárquico llegaron a caer hasta el 28%
Con todo, el jubileo de platino de la reina
y todos los homenajes tras su fallecimiento
parece que han vuelto a equilibrar algo las
cosas.
La pregunta es, ¿será una especie de efecto
champagne?
Pues ahí tenéis otro reto.
Sea como sea, hoy por hoy parece improbable
que en el corto plazo los republicanos consigan
su objetivo ya que además de una mayoría
a nivel nacional tendrían que lograr también
la mayoría en al menos 4 de los 6 estados
federales de Australia.
Algo similar ocurre en Canadá.
Si este país quisiera deshacerse de la monarquía
necesitaría conseguir el llamado consentimiento
unánime: esto es ni más ni menos que lograr
una mayoría de la Cámara de los Comunes,
el Senado y las diez legislaturas provinciales.
Vamos, que parece más factible que los británicos
echen a los Windsor de Buckingham Palace antes
de que los canadienses decidan convertirse
en una república.
Claro que otros países lo tendrían mucho
más sencillo.
(En Nueva Zelanda, bastaría una ley del parlamento
para eliminar la monarquía pero su primera
ministra, Jacinda Ardern, ha descartado que
dar este paso esté entre sus planes a corto
plazo.
Asimismo, muchos países del Caribe también
podrían volverse republicanos sin realizar
un referéndum.
Sin embargo, en el pasado varios Estados no
han cumplido sus promesas de hacerlo como
Jamaica.
En 2009 San Vicente y las Granadinas celebró
un referéndum republicano que fracasó igual
que había fracasado un año antes en Barbados.
Claro que en este último caso, al final Barbados
optó por convertirse en república mediante
una enmienda constitucional aprobada por dos
tercios de su Parlamento.)
Y más de uno os preguntaréis: ¿y qué pasa
en Reino Unido?
¿acaso no hay republicanos?
Pues la verdad es que hasta el momento el
apoyo a la monarquía parlamentaria se mantiene
con una sólida ventaja de 3 frente a 1.
Asimismo, la figura del monarca es la institución
más respetada en todo Reino Unido.
Porque ya sabemos que si hay algo que decepciona
a los británicos son sus políticos.
Y además, no olvidemos que aun con todas
sus limitaciones, la casa real sigue siendo
un poderoso mecanismo de influencia internacional.
Al fin y al cabo compartir jefatura del estado
con Australia, Canadá o Nueva Zelanda no
está nada mal para mantener vivos los vínculos
políticos, sociales, culturales y económicos.
De hecho, tras el Brexit, este puede convertirse
en el gran papel de la Casa Real.
Y de momento la Jefatura de la Commonwealth
no es poca cosa.
Así que, oye, hace bien el Gobierno en proteger
la monarquía.
Y de hecho la nueva líder del Ejecutivo no
ha tardado ni un minuto en evitar cualquier
tentación de Carlos III de convertirse de
nuevo en Black Spider.
(El rey Carlos no asistirá a la cumbre climática
por consejo de Truss)
Pero llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
todos vosotros:
¿Creéis que Carlos III será un buen rey?
¿Pensáis que muchos reinos de la Commonwealth
intentarán convertirse en repúblicas al
faltar una figura tan emblemática como Isabel
II?
¿Qué peso tendrá el nuevo monarca en la
política internacional del Reino Unido post-Brexit?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.